[Musique]
pratiquer son sport favori sur un plan
d'eau de 10 hectares
[Musique]
niché dans un écrin de weert
avec une eau à 29 degrés rien que du
plaisir
outre le ski nautique la discipline qui
désormais fait sensation
c'est loïc folle wec phone
l'association du wakeboard w à cao qui
veut dire sillage wakeboard c'est la
plancha sillage et le foll c'est cette
partie métallique qui est une partie
effectivement qui va rester dans l'eau
cette partie là et le rider va pouvoir
oscillé entre cette partie haute et
cette partie basse qui va lui permettre
de voler au dessus vous attend à 10 ans
et c'est déjà une graine de champion
c'est une histoire de famille son frère
son père et sa grand mère aussi tous
adeptes de sports nautiques extrême
[Musique]
tc trouvé son centre d'équilibré à céder
grosse sensation dans l'impression que
tu voles et comme si tu marchais dans
l'est un don est tombé dedans quand il
était tout petit
le ski nautique qui le pratique depuis
qu'il advint caen est désormais il
participe aux compétitions ont dû
traverser arabo faut être trois et puis
les gens pas trop être dans l'air et la
compétition tu aimes bien j'aime bien
parce que ça met un peu plus de stress
et j'arrive mieux c'était pas trop mal
fait attention à des changements de
quart quand tu arrives sur la bouée
florent pignon n'est pas seulement le
papa il est aussi l'entraîneur et
veillent au grain en compétition un
passage réussi on augmente la vitesse de
trois kilomètres/heure en trois
kilomètres heure jusqu'à un maximum
qu'on va avoir de 58 km heure pour les
hommes et de 55 km heure pour les femmes
en attendant l'arrivée des adeptes de
ski nautique le jeune adam a pour lui
tout seul le ciel et les
[Musique]